this lawsuit forced a YouTuber to give
away and abandon one of the coolest
Mustang builds of all time because of a
BS lawsuit B is for build had to turn
over a custom Eleanor inspired Mustang
Resto mod but now the tables have turned
so it's no surprise that on the big
screen movie cars can be iconic and
instantly recognizable almost as much as
human stars and one of the most famous
big screen cars is the 1967 Ford Mustang
Shelby GT500 better known as Eleanor
from the 2000 remake of Gone in 60
seconds starting in the cage now Denise
hulecki whose late husband H.B halecki
directed the original 1974 Gone in 60
Seconds has long claimed that Eleanor is
more than just a car but a distinctive
movie character protected by copyright
and for the past two decades halecki's
lawyers have threatened and even sued
any and all individuals that dare make
their own unauthorized Eleanor and that
includes individuals like Chris
steinbecker of the B is for build
YouTube channel who tried to create a
Frankenstein Eleanor using components of
a 2015 Mustang GT and the body of of a
1967 Mustang Fastback and after
receiving a threatening season desist
letter from Hawaii's attorney about
Eleanor Chris stopped his Eleanor
rebuild deleted all 14 videos of the
construction of the car and surrendered
that then still in process custom
vehicle to miss halecki now while a lot
of this might sound like a case of what
we lawyers like to call being a total
buzz kill courts have actually ruled
that fictional non-sentient cars like
the Batmobile for example can sometimes
be sufficiently defined in media to
constitute independently copyrightable
characters but now that the courts have
weighed in on Ms halecki's claim let's
talk about whether she was right to make
the demand in the first place whether
Chris was right to turn over the car
itself and delete all of his videos and
whether he can get Eleanor back so how
did we get here with Eleanor and more
importantly what even is in Eleanor well
there are a few key figures when it
comes to all of this Eleanor litigation
the first is Denise alecki who sued for
and was granted the rights to the
original Gone in 60 Seconds movie when
her husband and original Eleanor Creator
H.P halecki died in a stun accident
reportedly he his last words before
being consumed in a massive Fireball
were tell my wife to protect my
intellectual property then there's
Automotive designer Carol Shelby famous
for the Shelby Mustang in the early
2000s Shelby created the commercial
replicas of the Eleanor used in the 2000
remake of Lucky's film uh Denise and
Carol Shelby fought over who had the
rights to the 2000 version of Eleanor
for years even after Shelby's death in
2012. and finally we have Chris
steinbecker of B is for build on YouTube
which Chronicles Chris and his friends
as they build and restore custom
Vehicles it's one of my favorite
channels on YouTube and they make some
of the most incredible cars on the
platform and if you're a car guy like
myself Chris and his crew really work
Magic on a lot of old cars so definitely
check it out now in the original 1974
Gone in 60 Seconds Eleanor is a yellow
and black 1971 Ford Mustang Sports roof
modified to look like a 1973 Mustang
Eleanor is even named in the opening
credits and that yellow and black 71
Mustang appears in two sequels to the
original film the junk man and deadline
Auto theft which used recycled clips
from the first film it's not surprising
if you haven't seen any of these movies
but in the 2000 Nick Cage remake elnor
is a significantly modified Dupont
pepper gray 1967 Ford Mustang Shelby
GT500 this version of the car is the one
that's probably most recognizable as
Eleanor in this day and age now for two
decades Denise halecki had aggressively
fought to prevent unauthorized Eleanor
replicas that's something that Chris
from bees for build found out the hard
way when he tried to build his own
custom homage to Eleanor in a series of
14 YouTube videos starting in April of
2020. using a salvaged 2015 S550 Ford
Mustang GT frame as a base Chris
installed a 1967 vintage body on top of
the vehicle for his own take on the
classic car the project was going to be
great until lawyers had to do what
lawyers had to do and ruined all the fun
well details at the time were scarce
Hawaii's lawyer sent Chris a cease and
desist letter asserting that his car
project violated to like his
intellectual property rights in Eleanor
and then threatened litigation if he did
stop in response Chris took down all the
prior videos of his Eleanor rebuild and
even agreed to allow the purportedly
alleging vehicle to be seized by Miss
halecki
now on June 1st 2020 Chris released a
video entitled my lawyer made me change
the name of this episode so I wouldn't
get sued where he explains why he had to
scrap the Eleanor project I didn't know
it at the time but I recently found out
that Eleanor the car from the movie is
actually a copyrighted and trademarked
character from that movie the Mustang
that we had built is now property of
Gone in 60 Seconds and the build the
Mustang build is is over it's done and
while Chris was diplomatic in his video
under advice of counsel he was pointedly
less reserved when asked for comment
quote I do know that I can give my
opinion on the team at Gone in 60
seconds.com and tell you they are
terrible people parading around his car
people with a history of being lawsuit
happy just the most unpleasant
terrible people I've ever had The
Misfortune to have to deal with in my
life and that's not just me being mad
about what happened it's just the way
these people decided to handle
themselves now we've covered copyright
law in many previous videos but to
summarize the concept briefly copyright
protection extends to authors of any
original work fixed in a tangible medium
of expression such as novels movies
comic books and even software
architecture or a statue now the holder
of a copyright owns a set of exclusive
rights to make and sell copies of their
creations and Grant licenses to third
parties to create independent derivative
works now courts have long held the
fictional characters can obtain
protection separate from the underlying
Works where they appear now in the 1930
case of Nichols versus Universal
Pictures judge Learned Hand established
the first test for granting copyright
protection to an individual character
writing quote the less developed the
characters the less they can be
copyrighted that is the penalty an
author must bear for marking them to
indistinctly and we've seen lots of
characters get protection like James
Bond Fred Flintstone and Wonder Woman
Who are more than just the thing that
appears in the particular film TV show
or graphic novel that they happen to
appear at that particular time but what
about cars well certainly there are
fictional cars with distinctive
anthropomorphic character traits like
Pixar's Lightning McQueen or kit from
Knight Rider but really in all of those
cases those are characters who just
happen to be cars but can copyright
protection extend to non-sentient
Vehicles well in 2015 the night circuit
formerly ruled that yes non-sentient
cards like the Batmobile can be
classified as a character subject to
copyright protection well at least in
the ninth circuit and that's pretty
important for this particular scenario
because for Years Mark towel has made
and sold replicas of famous TV and movie
Cars through his auto shop Gotham Garage
but when he made a replica of Batmobiles
in 2011 DC Comics and Warner Brothers
sued Gotham Garage for copyright and
trademark infringement tell Fridley
admitted to copying Batmobile designs
from the 1966 TV series starring Adam
West and the 1989 film starring Michael
Keaton and in his defense tal argued
that cars like the Batmobile are not
independently copyrightable but the
district court disagreed ruling in 2013
natal did not copy the design of Amir
car he copied the Batmobile character
tal appealed to the ninth circuit but
the three judge panel unanimously
affirmed the lower court with an opinion
dripping with pop culture references and
rhetorical flourishes like holy
copyright law Batman and then it's
ruling the 9th circuit established a
three-part test for determining whether
a fictional character is entitled to
copyright protection the character has
quote physical as well as conceptual
qualities the character is sufficiently
delineated to be recognizable as the
same character whenever it appears and
displays consistent identifiable
character traits and attributes though
the character need not always look the
same and the character must be quote
especially distinctive and contains some
unique elements of expression after a
detailed analysis the ninth circuit
found that the Batmobile met all three
of these elements and after finding that
the Batmobile was a copyrightable
character the panel concluded its
opinion as follows as Batman so safely
told Robin quote in our well-ordered
society protection and private property
is essential yes Legal Eagles that is an
actual line by Adam West from the
original Batman series but that takes us
back to the litigation between Denise
halecki and Carol Shelby now in the
early 2000s Carol Shelby sought to
capitalize on popularity of the Gone in
60 Seconds remake and the attention it
had brought to the 1960s Shelby cars in
2002 the Carroll Hall Shelby trust
applied for the trademark Eleanor for
use in automobiles and structural parts
of automobiles and after the trademark
was granted in 2004 Shelby licensed
Unique Motor Cars Inc to start
manufacturing and selling vehicles that
resembled the remakes version of Eleanor
the modified 1967 Shelby GT500 and in
May 2004 Miss halecki sued unique and
various Shelby entities for copyright
infringement trademark infringement and
related torts she argued that she owned
the exclusive copyright to Eleanor and
demanded the cancellation of Shelby's
Eleanor trademark in November 2008 the
ninth circuit held Eleanor could
potentially be entitled to Independent
copyright protection because quote the
Eleanor character can be seen as more
akin to a comic book character than a
literary character the court then
remanded the halecki case back to the
district court to undertake the fact
specific analysis to quote examine
whether Eleanor's physical as well as
conceptual qualities and unique elements
of expression qualify Eleanor for
copyright protection and after years of
litigation the parties settled their
claims in 2009 so we actually don't know
how the court would have decided that
particular case but as part of the
settlement Shelby surrendered all claims
to any intellectual property rights to
Eleanor and the Shelby trust formally
assigned its Eleanor trademark to
halecki and due to the party's
settlement the issue of whether Eleanor
was a movie character protected by
copyright was not definitively decided
but this Automotive piece in our time
would not last as the parties found
themselves back in court a decade later
fighting over Eleanor again and after a
few years of settlement the Shelby Trust
basically did exactly the same thing
again they contracted with a car shop to
make Eleanor replicas from the Remake
halecki again demanded the Shelby trust
knock it off oh here we go again
and then the Shelby party sued for
breach of the settlement agreement
arguing that Eleanor was not a
copyrightable character a lucky counter
suit for copyright infringement and also
breach of the settlement agreement as
well now given the new case law in the
intervening years about character
development the Shelby trust had way
more ammunition time around and in the
trial court the judge sat down to
independently scrutinize all four films
in which Eleanor appears which is what
judges should do it's one of the reasons
why copyright cases can be adjudicated
so quickly is because really often all
you're looking at is one TV or film
comparing it to another TV film or
screenplay and the judge is completely
capable of making an independent
determination just looking at the art
itself and after the movie marathon in
this particular case the judge
discovered that the Hawaii parties had
previously exaggerated some of the
content of these films quote much of the
ninth circuit panels commentary on the
copyright ability issue appears to have
stemmed from an unfortunate practice on
the part of the halecki parties to
embellish facts in their briefing
several of these exaggerations were left
unchallenged and made their way into
court orders when this matter was before
prior judicial officers so for example
the ninth circuit previously wrote the
quote thefts of the other cars go
largely as planned but whenever the main
human character tries to seal Eleanor
circumstances in invariably become
complicated except as the judge noted
here the conclusion is plainly false the
judge then gives several examples of
Thieves having setbacks like a thief
discovering a live tiger in a car in the
original film or how the Remake quote
keys for three vehicles must be
retrieved from the bowels of a canine by
feeding it laxatives and the judge went
on to write quote well the court
recognized the importance of zealous
advocacy parties need to always be
mindful of their obligations to be
candid with the court and fulfill their
obligations under rule 11b rule 11 is
the sanctions provision in the federal
rules of civil procedure which you don't
want a judge saying that you are
skirting that particular line the judge
then applied the three-part DC Comics
Daniels test for independently
copyrightable characters to Eleanor and
after providing detailed movie summaries
the judge found that Eleanor's
inconsistent depictions between the
films illustrate that Eleanor was not
sufficiently delineated with
consistently identifiable traits as to
be recognizable the court further
described the Hawaii party's efforts to
assign anthropomorphic characteristics
to Eleanor like strength Talent
endurance and a tendency to always save
her Leading Men as nothing more than an
invention of overzealous advocacy so the
court concluded that quote Eleanor is
not entitled to Standalone copyright
protection as a matter of law so what's
the impact of this ruling well those who
want to buy and sell officially licensed
Shelby GT500 models will still need to
get a license from the Shelby trust fans
who just want to make their own homage
to Eleanor can probably rest easier that
is unless halecki decides to appeal the
ruling and prevails so we'll have to
wait and see on that so Chris was
ultimately Vindicated by the ruling
though it likely brought him no real
Comfort a commenter on the video about
the Eleanor build asked Chris if he
would be getting the car returned to him
and Chris responded with a simple no and
that's because regardless of whether
there was any Merit to the original
lawsuit the terms of the settlement
agreement are likely still enforced
that's a contract between the two
parties so unfortunately there's
probably nothing that he can do to get
it back and on February 1st 2023 Chris
released a video responding to the
Eleanor ruling and it he highlighted
just how aggressive Hawaii's attorneys
were in connection with the Eleanor
project nevertheless he claims he
approached to like he's lawyers in good
faith to resolve the issue I offered to
remove any name and likeness of Eleanor
from all the episodes I offered to
change the build to something completely
different than anything related to
Eleanor I offered everything I could
imagine and the response that I got from
that was not good it was a lot of nasty
threats and Chris reluctantly agreed to
comply with the cease and desist letter
after concluding the teleki's plan was
to inflict Financial pain on the Channel
with a costly lawsuit which I think
Chris correctly identifies as a slap
lawsuit it was just simply the threat of
an expensive lawsuit regardless of
whether it was going to be successful or
not but luckily when halecki's lawyers
threatened to sue over a completely
unrelated 2007 Mustang GT project which
had nothing to do with Eleanor Chris's
lawyers apparently told them to go kick
rocks rather than pay any monetary
resettlement and Chris says he hasn't
heard from Hawaii's lawyers since but
that's hardly Comfort to Chris who spent
ten thousand dollars on legal fees to
date now it's possible that the lucky
will appeal the decision of the trial
court and the copyright ability of the
Eleanor Carr but I think the ninth
circuit would probably affirm that
decision but their case is moving
forward against Shelby on contract
claims that Shelby breached the prior
settlement agreement because regardless
of copyright if you contract for
something it's generally an independent
right against the other Contracting
party which is also why Chris won't be
getting his Eleanor Bill back anytime
soon and after discussing halecki's
spectacular courtroom defeat Chris
explained why he would not be building
another Eleanor and why you might not
want to either a lot of it comes down to
who I want to support Carol Shelby is a
goddamn American hero one of the only
Americans ever to win the 24 Hours of Le
Mans and his impact on car culture
especially American Car culture cannot
even be measured then on the other hand
you have Denise hiliki so who do I want
to support more definitely Carol Shelby
but I think Chris already got the last
laugh because the white 67 Mid Engine
wide-bodied Mustang Fastback that he
built is already 10 times cooler than
any Eleanor now if you want to build or
engineer your own totally not copyright
infringing Mustang you'll probably want
to Bone up on your math and science
skills which you can do with today's
sponsor brilliant brilliant.org is the
best way to learn math and computer
science interactively brilliant is an
online learning platform for stem that
replaces lecture videos with Hands-On
interactive lessons it's for Curious
Learners both young and old professional
and inexperienced you can quickly learn
to Ace your high school or college math
courses or just learn stuff that you
always wanted to learn brilliant helps
you reach your goals whether you're a
student or a professional looking to get
ahead for example there are classical
mechanics course even starts with an
explanation of Formula One racing the
course teaches core principles of
physics to understand matter in motion
from drones to fireflies and another one
of my favorite courses is all about
Logic the logic courses cover liar and
juiceeller riddles logical fallacies
machine logic and even some strategic
game theory because brilliant lets you
learn by doing rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures it's all
interactive and fun now you can sign up
and start learning for free by going to
brilliant.org legaleagle or clicking on
the link that's on screen right now if
you click on that link you'll get a free
30-day trial plus the first 200 people
to sign up will also get 20 off their
annual subscription so by clicking on
the link below you'll get a free 30-day
trial and 20 off your subscription to
brilliant plus clicking on that link
really helps out this Channel and after
that click on this box for more legal
eagle or I'll see you in court